michelle starts us off this hour in
memphis
hi michelle how are you i'm good i'm
good how are you guys
better than we deserve how can we help
great
um i bought my home two years ago for
two hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
and just two years later when i got
married and i was able to sell my home
much to my surprise for 250 000.
great mike yes my question is
i believe in paying tithes and i was
wondering what is your opinion about
paying tithes on the equity or the sale
of your home
and if you think you should how is the
best to calculate that considering
closing costs paid and i purchased it
and sold it in minor improvements
okay uh well to start with let's
establish that as a christian you and i
what what i my belief is doesn't really
matter it's what scripture says
and so as best we can determine what the
bible says is what we should be
following you and me people like you and
me right
right and so first and foremost uh god
wants us to be givers
and he's not really wringing his hands
as to whether we figure out every
perfect thing to give on
and so i always try to over give like i
over
tip and then when i get to heaven i
don't to worry about it
but in other words i don't spend a whole
bunch of time
uh and a whole bunch of rules the tithe
is a tenth of your income from
deuteronomy it says a tenth of your
increase okay
and so what you have been increased is
250
minus 215 which would be 35
right right and you did you
net 250 after expenses selling
um i netted 31 000 uh because i owe
205. for the payoff and then i had no no
no no no
no no no no it's not your increase is
not over the payoff
you're equity because let's pretend you
put down 100 000
and you had already tithed on that
hundred thousand dollars correct
so that would that would have reduced
your loan amount by that so you wouldn't
want to tithe on that portion
over your loan amount you tithe over
what you paid for it
versus what you sold it for that's your
increase
so you paid 215 you told me right
right and so and you sold it for 250
minus expenses
and so you netted somewhere in the
neighborhood of
five 30 000 it sounds like right cause i
did pay um
realtors commission i think that was
about ten fifteen thousand
yeah so what you need to do is just dig
into your figures and say
what did you net after all your expenses
minus 215
would be your net increase that would
have been your quote profit
does that make sense yes sir you don't
have taxes on it because it's under
500 000 uh married or 250 single so
you're fine on that as your personal
residence you don't have any issue on
taxes
but that's how you would measure and so
the same thing in business say let's say
you owned a business
and you sold something uh you you made a
hundred thousand dollars gross revenue
that year
and you had a uh a 90 000 worth of
expenses to operate the business your
net profit is 10 000
so you would tithe on the 10 not the
100.
you see what i'm doing thank you yes sir
so what what did you
profit on something if you want to be
real technical and figure it out
but we also need to really say loud and
clear uh
that you know it's okay to not tithe on
that it's okay to
decide you want to do it a different way
it's okay to tithe at the end of the
story sometime
on the house deal i'm fine with that i'm
pretty i'm very diligent personally to
tithe on my
income but on you know some people tied
on the increase of their investment if
even if they hadn't sold it
yeah and i i wouldn't teach you to do
that
but you can do whatever you want to do
it's just the point is
the more detailed you get on it the more
you lose the spirit
of why god has us to be generous yeah
it's really about the first fruits if
you really look at it
and you break it down it's the idea that
i've been given something
and and so then i'm going to give back
as a acknowledgement of the source
that's the spirit that you're talking
about so yeah you know if you want to
tithe off of a bigger number and yours
your
your breakdown is different than dave's
again that's that's between you and god
because the
again the what we what we teach is what
we believe which is you know
you give of you the first fruits and so
however you define that off the top
that's the top of your of your
net increase right deuteronomy 28 pretty
clear on that and that's the guiding
principle but the big principle is this
100
of what we have for those of us that are
people of faith is not ours anyway we're
managing it that's exactly right
and so it doesn't matter it's all his to
start with
and so i'm just managing it for him so
i'm going to manage some of it
by giving it over here into the local
church as a tithe
and a recognition as you said of the
source
and and looking at that so what we're
looking at here is this is a whole lot
more about spirit than it is detail
and when you get there that's what i
mean i always i joke and say
when i get to heaven i don't be wrong
but this is just a joke the bottom line
is i'm going to get to heaven and it
doesn't matter
because i never owned any of it anyway
and so
it's not it's not relevant to get all
and i'm not suggesting michelle's all
twisted up about it but i meet people
who
spend an inordinate amount of energy
legalistically trying to figure out how
much they should give yeah
and just just kind of ballpark it and
then give some more
and you really can't mess up generosity
no
yeah and and that you know what you tell
us what my parents always modeled for us
my brother and i you know it was it was
it was always a phrase this is a churchy
phrase for those of you listening you
don't go to church very often but it was
always
tithes and offerings this idea that 10
is is is commanded and then offerings is
this is above and beyond
that's what you've talked about and
you've really modeled that in your life
you model it
not just personally you insurance but
you model with the way our company gives
and the way we give
of of of our profits the way we give of
our time as a company we go and do
things and so
it is a spirit of gratitude that we're
talking about a gratitude for
uh the blessing the gratitude to the
source
and acknowledging that hey this is yours
and and when we show that
the principle is and we've seen the
evidence of this
is that when we take on that spirit and
we do it in a form of
obedience and demonstrate the gratitude
then we are given more to manage
yeah we are given more to steward the
more rules you put on your generosity
the more you lose there's no gratitude
that's the fun of it yeah you feel like
oh this is find anything right right
and giving is one of the most fun things
you'll ever do with money
and again that's not this is just
expanding on the question michelle you
had a valid question we're not
suggesting it's not valid
it is very valid and i appreciate you
asking it and we gave you the correct
answer
but i the point being that we get a lot
of other stuff around this subject
coming at us and it's really good to
just be very very clear
um you know
god's not upset with you he's not mad at
you
it's okay and being generous
is it changes everything generous people
are
highly attractive you really can't mess
this up